what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back from my Game of Thrones Season 7
preview video this is not a preview
trailer breakdown video but I just
finished watching episode 5 so now I
want to talk about the main event that
is coming up in the next episode which
should be pretty damn amazing I have
been waiting for episode 6 for so long
now and I'm so excited that it's finally
the next episode that we're going to see
for those of you that I've been
subscribed to my channel for a long time
already know how hyped I have been for
this mission beyond the wall I have
already made so many videos about what
could possibly happen during this
episode and mainly what will happen when
Jon Snow and company get into a battle
with the army of the Dead I will be
talking about some major spoilers in his
videos so make sure you proceed with
caution if you do not want to hear any
because what I say in this video will
most likely come true I am beyond
excited for this episode so let's begin
all right folks this stage is now being
set up for us to see one of the best
episodes in Game of Thrones history at
least in my opinion till this day
hardhome is still one of my favorite
episodes because we finally got to see
some main characters battle it out with
the army of the Dead which is something
I have wanted to see ever since the very
first episode of this entire series I
still remember when I watched the first
episode and we were first introduced to
the Nights Watch when they went beyond
the wall and we got our first glimpse of
the White Walkers I thought to myself I
cannot wait to see what happens when we
actually see a war between the living
and the dead we did get a small taste of
that at hardhome but in this next
episode we're going to get so much more
than that we will finally see ice burst
fire the Dragons burst the dead and it's
going to be [ __ ] incredible I don't
know about all of you that are watching
and listening to this but ever since the
dragons were hatched from their eggs I
have been waiting to see the dragons and
the White Walkers and the same scene
together this whole time I know it may
be hard to believe for some of you
because Daenerys hasn't fully committed
to helping Jon fight the others but in
episode 6 Daenerys will fly up north
with her three dragons and take them
beyond the wall in hopes that she can
save Jon and his companions that will be
surrounded by the night Kings army just
seeing this group of characters fighting
together against the common enemy is
going to be incredible back at the
beginning of this season
John held a meeting and he told tormund
to go to eastwatch-by-the-sea with the
wildling zijn man the wall because as we
all know the Nights Watch is extremely
low on men
so torment is already there but now we
have the Brotherhood without banners in
the Hound at eastwatch-by-the-sea it's
going to be so much fun watching torment
and the Hound share some screen time
together the hound and the Brotherhood
without banners are on there Lord of
Light mission following what the hound
saw in the flames because they know that
dead are marching on the wall and
they're not going to stop unless someone
starts them brain stark has also seen
the same thing and he sent word to Jon
Snow on Dragonstone that the dead are
coming and they are heading for
eastwatch-by-the-sea the night king and
his army will be marching past the
mountain that is shaped like an arrow
headed just like the hound saw in the
flames the assault on the wall will
happen at eastwatch-by-the-sea so this
is where the defenses will need to be
the strongest in order to stop the night
king or at least slow his ass down but
Jon will never have the support in time
to stop him before the army of the Dead
make it south of the wall Jon Snow will
be arriving with a nice little team of
his own
now that bran has sent word to Jon about
the night king heading for east watch
jon is ready to give these [ __ ] a
fight and get the proof that he needs so
he can get the support that he needs Jon
Davos Gendry and Jorah will arrive at
east wats where they will meet torment
the Hound in the Brotherhood are there
too
Jon needs to go beyond the wall so who
better to take with him than men that
are already prepared to go these men
will be in together and head out into
the wilderness beyond the wall in search
of the dead personally I hope the scenes
beyond the wall will take up the
majority of this episode kind of like
how they did with Hart home so much is
going to be happening during this attack
I just hope they don't try and condense
it into short scenes because once Jon
and company make contact with the army
of the Dead all hell is going to break
loose unfortunately we are going to lose
some beloved characters during this
mission in the first episode of this
season we saw some of the night kings
secret weapons he had at least three
giants in his army but this isn't the
only thing he will have with him the
night king also has a polar bear in his
army and there are snow bears in the
books too so they didn't just pull this
out of their ass
but Thoris of Mir will be our first big
casualty on this mission forest will be
shredded by this bear but he's not going
to die right away but carrying around a
severely injured man will definitely
slow them down
when Thoris of Mir dies beric Dondarrion
is going to be kind of screwed Thoris
was able to bring him back from the dead
six times
so once Thoris is gone berrak will
essentially be on his last life in the
books barek also has the ability to
bring people back from the dead
but when he does it he has to sacrifice
himself to bring them back it's going to
be interesting to see if they give beric
this power in the television show to
bear it could give someone the last kiss
that is a much more important character
than he is but I don't think they're
going to do that during this episode but
Barret could potentially give Thoreau's
the kiss since Thor saved his ass so
many times but like I said they probably
won't be doing this just yet at least
but while all of this is going on while
they are under attack Daenerys will
finally decide to come and help them
Daenerys will take off from Dragonstone
with all three of her dragons and take
them up north Tyrion will advise against
this but Daenerys will ignore him once
again which will make tearing an
extremely worried as he watches Daenerys
leave Dragonstone Daenerys will arrive
providing dragon ex machina as John and
company are surrounded on all sides
finally after all these years we will
finally get to see ice burst fire
Daenerys is going to show up and start
wrecking these whites with her dragon
fire killing them by the dozens at once
which will allow everyone to escape but
John of course John has to be the hero
and stay back and fight them off while
everyone climbs on drug on and now I
know some of you don't believe this
because we haven't seen anyone get on
her dragons except her writings rogue on
this will be pretty interesting to see
because you don't have to actually be a
Targaryen to get on a dragon but
typically a dragon will only have one
writer at a time like Aegon the
conquerer would never get on one of his
sisters dragons and neither of his
sisters would actually get on his dragon
so it will be crazy seeing almost a
dozen people get on drogon I don't know
how they're going to explain this in
this show but honestly I really don't
care at this point because a lot of
things happen that really don't make any
sense I'm just going to enjoy this being
the spectacle
that it is during all this chaos somehow
the hound is going to capture a white
and take it with him too and I'm not
sure how he's going to keep it secure on
a damn dragon but he will get the damn
thing back to the wall somehow it does
say that John's going to try and climb
on Jorgen too but he will fall off as
drug on takes off the fly to safety
which will leave John all alone and
still surrounded by the whites but
before Daenerys is actually able to
leave something insane is going to
happen something a lot of people don't
want to see and some people still don't
believe but the night king will kill one
of her dragons Viserion Daenerys will
lose a dragon and this is going to
change the outcome of the entire show
not only will the knight king's army be
even stronger with a damn dragon but
this will also weaken Daenerys his
chances of beating Cersei Daenerys has
been taking losses all season long
and she has one of this her entire life
and now she finally gets to Westeros
with what looks like an unstoppable
force and she ends up getting her ass
kicked in almost every single episode
since she arrived the entire series is
going to change after this episode it's
going to be crazy this season is going
to end dramatically after the night king
kills Viserion john will be saved just
in time by his uncle Benjen and i got to
be honest with you this is going to be
heartbreaking
I know benjin is no longer a normal
person but him sacrificing himself for
his nephew is going to be very emotional
john loves his uncle Benjen so much I
mean John wanted to be just like him he
wanted to be in the Nights Watch he
wanted to be a ranger just like his
uncle when benjin went missing years ago
John has thought about this for years
always wondering where his uncle was and
to finally see him again
during the absolute worst situation and
to see him die almost immediately will
be crushing not only for John but for
the viewers too I was actually hoping
this wasn't going to be true I didn't
want to see benjin die just yet but when
you see Jon riding off on the horse and
a trailer you just have to know that's
his uncle benjen's horse after he saves
him from being surrounded unfortunately
with uncle benjen's death we are going
to lose a stark this season and we might
even see benjin again in season eight as
a full-blown white fighting what the
night came and there might even come a
time when Jon comes face to face
his uncle during the Great War and John
may have to kill him for good making it
an even worse reunion than the last one
now that the series is winding down
towards the end game it's only going to
continue to get crazier and crazier the
night King is going to have a [ __ ]
dragon now and he will use this dragon
and Giants and bears and possibly even
spiders to wreak havoc upon Westeros
it's going to be extremely intense and I
cannot wait to see it continue to unfold
I am wondering what this is going to do
to Daenerys psychologically she looks at
her dragons like they are her kids how
much do you think this is going to
change her after she loses a dragon to
the night King I could see her character
getting even darker and more desperate
after this I'm not going to say she's
going to go mad because everyone keeps
saying that but this will significantly
change her from here on out when Jon
Snow and company escaped with the white
the night King is going to be pretty
damn pissed that Jon Snow was able to
get away from him again and now that he
has a dragon added to his army he will
be heading straight for East watch next
and it's going to be the start of an
all-out war the Great War will have
officially begun but let's just hope Jon
is able to rally the realm in time
before everyone else is killed and
turned into more meat for the night
king's army let me know what you think
down below I'm anxious to see what all
of you have to say about this so please
if you have any insight put it down
below because I'd love to hear from all
of you I am going to work on my episode
5 breakdown now that way I can release
it tomorrow then I'm going to start
working on that episode 6 preview
trailer breakdown so I can release that
to you by Tuesday I want to thank
everyone for stopping by and watching
another one of my videos I really really
appreciate that all of you wonderful
people have been showing this channel
more support than nearly every other
channel out there including ones that
are bigger than mine I just wanted to
say I love all of you for that and I
work harder every day so I can keep
bringing new videos to show my
appreciation in some way because this is
by far the strongest support group in
the community I also want to thank my
patreon supporters who show their
continued support month after month
without me even asking anyone to do so
all of you truly are the greatest have a
great night I will see you tomorrow with
the breakdown
by
[Music]
[Music]